l'histoire répète encore après
[Musique]
25 ans arrivé à Québec il y a près de 10
ans les mouhibie constate avec
désolation et inquiétude la situation de
leur pays d'origine 25 ans après l'avoir
fui on peut pas imaginer comment elles
sont vives à cette situation
spécialement avec les droits de femmes
car sous le régime des talibans le voile
intégrale en public pour les femmes et
de nouveaux obligatoires alors que
l'école secondaire leur a été interdite
goolson
resserre la vessie interdisent les cols
aussi pour les plus jeunes filles comme
c'était le cas pour elle à l'époque non
jamais allé
bancs et depuis que moi je suis grandi
beaucoup de problèmes dans mon pays
et aujourd'hui c'est la même chose c'est
la même chose après 4 ans de démarche le
couple a pu accueillir à Québec le
cousin de Karim le mois dernier ils
espèrent maintenant pouvoir faire venir
leur cousines toujours coincée en
Afghanistan mais le processus est
compliqué et on a trouvé encore rien
aucune réponse de cette journée depuis
le début de la crise le Canada accueilli
plus de 17000 réfugiés afghans sur un
objectif de 40000 en deux ans 15 d'entre
eux se sont installés à Québec dans la
dernière année
si le processus est long et ardu de
nouveaux arrivants peuvent compter sur
le comité d'accueil aux réfugiés pour
faciliter leur arrivée pendant un an on
est responsable de la famille qui arrive
on les accompagne dans toutes les
démarches administratives le citrouille
ont d'ailleurs accueilli Karine
gousselane et leurs deux enfants en
septembre 2012 il leur ont trouvé un
toit et des biens essentiels 10 ans plus
tard ils sont maintenant citoyens
canadiens parfaitement bien intégré
c'est un succès story quand on est
arrivé ici tout était prêt pour nous
éternellement reconnaissant les moabi se
sont liés d'amitié avec ceux qui les ont
parrainés c'est des gens qui sont
absolument attachants et pour qui
une admiration semble ici